well pretty regularly you hear about the
appeal to donate blood but what if your
pet is severely injured or facing a
life-threatening disease who helps them
well Las Vegas does have an animal blood
bank it serves dogs and cats and last
year alone 540 units were used to save
animals so in this special report we'll
tell you where the donations come from
and how to find out if your pup can be a
lifesaver come on back for Riot and his
owner Sherry klemke this isn't an
ordinary vet visit I'm going to have
some paperwork for you to fill out the
four-year-old golden mix was rescued
from a meat farm in South Korea once he
was big enough to travel they shipped
him over and we adopted him now he might
be able to save another dog's life by
becoming a blood donor blood type for
dogs is pretty extensive only a small
percentage of dogs qualify but donors
are always needed so Riot is getting
screened there it is good job the
requirements age one to six at least 55
pounds current on vaccinations good
health good temperament I do actually
Kelly tantello helps run the bank at the
Las Vegas Veterinary Specialty Center we
actually provide blood to all the other
hospitals in the city as well if they
need it they can come to us and grab it
dogs who are sick dogs who are injured
all depend on this inventory cats too
anything that comes in um that's had
some sort of trauma there's actually a
lot of diseases that are out there where
we need to give them blood to help kind
of recuperate their bodies the testing
is extensive and expensive but the
hospital covers the cost they extend
discounts and offer other perks too but
a number of dogs have retired recently
so they need new ones any Healthy dog
that especially Super Active dogs
they're they're they are great for
donations as well most dogs donate every
couple of months but the shelf life is
shorter than that blood 42 days
platelets a little longer it's basically
like when we give blood klemke is a
regular donor herself elf the idea that
her dog can do the same means a lot we
hope we can save another life
so to see those requirements for the
blood bank to make an appointment for
your vet will have all those information
for you on our website and also to learn
more about Retriever Rescue of Las Vegas
and their work saving dogs from the meat
train I have links for both of those
groups for you on our website at
8newsnow.com